I'd like to ask each other
about our early experiences.
Sure.
Okay.
Why don't you...
...in French?
What happened to me in French?
All right.
Okay.
That's a good start.
I'd like to
...
yeah, go ahead.
Hello?
Okay.
I think we're live.
So we have the two Steves here.
that's right.
We have the two Steves.
We have Dr.
Steven Krashen, who is to me, the
person who has explained the world,
the sort of snake pit of Pandora's
box of how you learn languages.
And he's reduced it to something
that's very simple, which con...
basically confirms all of my
experience in language learning.
Dr.
Krashen the language acquisition
hypothesis, we're gonna get into that.
Very happy to have this
opportunity to speak with you.
And I'm very happy to be here
with my language consultant
and therapist, Steve Kaufmann.
Who's helped me in so many ways.
Let me tell you.
Well, that's very kind of you, you
know, you were saying just before
we went live here, that it would
be interesting to review our early
experiences in learning languages.
What, what did you have in mind?
Well, let me give you mine and
then you'll respond appropriately.
Okay.
Um, I grew up middle class privileged
in the, in Chicago and my, and I
heard Yiddish all around, but nobody
expected me to understand any of it.
And I didn't now I
can ... yiddish that comes later.
Okay.
That's another, that's another story.
A very happy one.
Um, uh, but I took French in high school.
I got a passing grade in French from
my kind teacher under the condition
that I never take any more French
courses at that high school, cuz
I was such a terrible student.
All right.
I had no interest in it.
It was boring.
I went to Hebrew school.
It was beyond boredom.
Then things happened.
My mom set it up.
So I would go on a tour, a bicycle tour,
a youth host tour of Europe, down the
Rhine Valley with a bunch of other kids.
Really nice.
We went to a youth host in Switzerland
and went to a party, nice kids everywhere.
I sat around and listened to a
conversation, basically being, uh,
managed by one young man who spoke
to some kids in French, some kids in
German and spoke to us in English.
And I thought that is so cool.
I wanna be like him when I grow
up, that really changed it.
And I decided on the spot that
I would get good at languages.
Uh, when the Peace Corps tour
was over, I went to Paris.
The advice of one of our leaders of
the group, I went to the Alliance
Française, took a couple of
weeks of French, got much better.
Came back, took French, took German.
And then the big breakthrough, my
major was music, piano and my piano
teacher, Malcolm Bilson, who is
wonderful, um, suggested I go to
Vienna and study with his teacher.
We had a terrible ... we had a horrible
argument, like one weekend and I, I
stopped with her, but I stayed in Vienna.
My parents were so nice and so generous.
Took German classes.
Got really good in German.
That was the real reason I got there.
And this is the end of
this, uh, little segment.
Um, everything I did was right.
I had a group of friends in those days.
English was not the lingua franca.
You spoke, we spoke German and a
lot of them were better than I was.
We recommended reading to each other,
which books were good and gradually
native speakers who liked to hang
out with foreigners joined the group.
That was a wonderful, perfect
immersion experience that got me going.
After that was the, oh, I'll just mention
three good things that happened in
Ethiopia that pushed me along: joined
the Peace Corps so I wouldn't have to
go to Vietnam and avoided the draft.
Uh, I learned to speak Amharic which was
a lot of fun, cuz people were so friendly.
Uh, and I met my wife there.
She joined the Peace Corps cuz she was
an idealist and wanted to help people.
So, and we're still married 55 years
later and it's still wonderful.
So these are good things that
happened and I discovered coffee.
Okay.
Aha.
Steve, tell us your story.
Well, with specific reference to
learning languages, first of all, the
number of things that you talked about
there, I can also confirm, first of
all, uh, uh, you know, at school, I,
I, unlike you, I did get good grades
in my French, uh, but I couldn't speak.
And, uh, and that was typical, like in
Canada, in the French language, other
than French immersion, which is a recent
phenomenon in Canada, I dunno, 10,
20 years people in the regular French
stream don't learn to speak French.
The better students get better grades.
The poorer students get poorer grades.
If one of the students has a
Francophone, Francophone parent,
they're probably gonna do better.
Uh, but by and large, they
don't learn in the classroom.
What happened to me was I
went to McGill university.
We had a, I took a course
in French civilization.
We had a professor, Maurice Rabotan, who
was a phenomenal professor, not because
he forced French at us, but because he
made the world of French civilization
history so interesting to me that I got
totally motivated and living in Montreal,
even though Montreal in those days was
two thirds French, one third English.
And if you lived in the English
part of Montreal, you might
just as well be in Chicago.
Uh, but if you want to access the
French language, there's radio,
there's newspapers, there's Montreal
University there's a whole bunch of
things that you can do, including
watching, you know, movies.
And, and eventually I went to France.
So it, it was my motivation to sort of
my interest in the language and, uh, the
other thing too, uh, you mentioned that
you, uh, met your wife in a way related to
your interest in the world and so forth.
And so did I, uh, I worked
for the Canadian government.
I was sent to Hong Kong to learn Mandarin,
Chinese, and I met my wife in Hong Kong
and we've been married for 53 years.
So we're catching up to you.
Uh, but certainly I discovered then
that all of the instruction about the
niceties of grammar and particularly
when the teachers select what you're
gonna read, so mostly you're not
interested in what they push at you.
And in those days there wasn't
so much in the way of, you
know, there were no MP3 files.
There weren't even cassette players.
So there was very little listening.
It was mostly reading with a
long list, word list and, and
things that were of no interest.
Once you get actually motivated
in what you're reading about, it
gets back to your compelling input.
Then you don't notice you're being
carried along by your interest in the
subject matter or your interest in
communicating with other people and
the language just starts to pile in.
So that, that has been my
experience, uh, with French.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
So when did the change come?
Well, like change be came very quickly.
See, one of the things I think
is although I'm a critic of,
um, school language instruction.
In fact, if you spent 10
years passively doing stuff in
French despite the effort...
oh, the, the interesting thing
is I went to a, a football game.
We have the Montreal Alouettes
and, uh, we had a problem with our
ticket and I had to explain this
to the usher who was a Francophone.
And so I had to kind of find some French
words at age 16 or 17 and I still remember
to this day that all I had was words.
I didn't have grammar.
The teachers had only taught grammar.
And all I could say was ... you
know,  like, I couldn't produce the
grammar, but what I did have was words.
And so I'm, I remained to this
day convinced that the best sort
of way to evaluate your, at least
your potential in the language
is how many words do you know?
You know, how many words
do you know, even passive.
So, uh, but yeah, but eventually of
course, once I got really interested
and I watched movies and I listened
to radio and then I went to France
and I had to do all my schooling in
French and write essays in French
and answer oral questions in French.
Of course then it just, it just cascades.
Yeah.
There you have it.
Very good.
I have a question that one of our
members at LingQ put on our forum.
And unfortunately Eric said he was
gonna find the name of this professor,
but there was a professor who did
some work, which showed, purported to
show that if you start speaking too
early, before you have 2000 hours of
listening or some number, then you might
develop some bad pronunciation habits.
Uh, Have you any thoughts on, you know,
when is the right time to start speaking?
That whole business and people I'm
sure they've asked you this before.
How do we transition from acquiring the
language, getting the language, getting,
getting the brain used to the language.
How do we get from there to output?
Okay.
I can give a partial answer to that.
I don't know the complete answer.
And that's a good research question
for eager scholars, I think, but
there is a problem with early
speaking and I'll tell you my story.
Um, we used to live down the street from
a family that had a daughter the same age
as our daughter at the time around five
years old, which is nearly 50 years ago.
Okay.
And I used to get the, we'd
get the girls together to play.
And one day it was my, my, um,
responsibility to pick up both girls after
an hour, bring her to my house because
the mom had to go off and take her Spanish
course at the local community college.
So I went up, I said,
okay, girls, let's go.
She said, wait, I have to take my pill.
She goes in the bathroom takes this pill.
And again, we are good family friends.
I said, what was that?
She said, well, today Valium, today
would be Prozac, anti-anxiety medication.
So again, relying on our close friendship,
I said, well, why are you taking Valium?
French class, it freaks me out.
And I said, what is it about French
class that makes you so nervous?
When the teacher calls on me
having to talk before I'm ready.
I interpret that as having to use
stuff you've consciously learned
and not being able to work on...
to use what you have acquired.
I thought this is something.
I looked at all the research
found more and it's all there.
One of the biggest anxiety producing
things is having to talk before
you're ready in a language class.
Now there's some interesting
anthropological research
that backs this up.
A guy named Sorenson went to the
Amazon Valley and looked at a group
of 10,000 people on the border
between two countries who spoke
like 24 languages, not all related.
10,000 is not that much.
You go to a football game there're
10,000 people in the stadium.
That's not very much, but, and so
this is really not a big number.
They were all pretty good in languages.
They picked up mommy's language,
daddy's language, language of their
friends, gradually the language
of all the local lingua franca
and were heavily monolingual.
So Sorenson interviewed them.
How do you do it?
We don't try to say anything.
We don't force it unless
we think we're ready.
We just wait, we just listen.
And then it comes.
By the way in that culture, you
are forbidden from correcting
anybody for doing anything.
Okay.
Other studies have found the same thing.
We go to another country and we
just stay there, be with the people
until we can hear the language,
which means understand it.
They say for them consistent
results, it takes a year or
two before you're comfortable.
We can actually, I think that's
true in the real environment where
you don't have extra support.
We can do better.
We have language classes.
We can give people comprehensible input
right away in a good language class,
which is what we're supposed to do.
So that backs up the point, the
reluctance with early speaking,
it could give you a bad accent.
I don't know, let's find out, but
it's the fear, the, uh, discomfort of
having to produce before you're ready.
Uh, and, and I would add in my experience,
I am more say intimidated, say I
have an online lesson with a tutor.
It bothers me more when I don't understand
what the other person is saying.
Uh, the fact that I stumble, especially
if it's with a tutor, so you're in a
protected environment, that's normal.
It's, it's, it's mildly annoying.
That words that I have been reading
and listening to, and I'm sure I know
the meaning of, and I've gone over it
many times and I get in front of my
tutor and I cannot find those words.
Those words are just not available to me.
But if I understand what the
teacher tutor is saying, I'm happy.
If on the other hand, I don't
understand that's a very uncomfortable.
Um, so yeah, I'm, I'm a firm believer
in that, but again, so, so, so then to
me, the question is like, how do you
evaluate someone in the language in a
way we shouldn't be evaluating others.
We shouldn't even be evaluating ourselves.
We should just enjoy the process, but
people do wanna know, well, am I B1 or B2?
You know, am I gonna take, take
the HSK or whatever TOEFL test?
Uh, so do you measure it entirely on
how well a person speaks or how well
they pronounce or, or, uh, how well
they understand and how do you even
measure their level of comprehension?
This it's, it's a big issue.
Like how do you evaluate people?
I have never been able to stay awake
during a discussion of testing and
how we should do it, cuz just for
the reasons you mentioned, it's an
external, uh, task imposed on us
and that's not what we're about.
Right?
Uh, just the tests pretty
well agree with each other.
So that's not a problem.
So it's, it's a question I
really would love to ignore.
Can we go onto the next one?
All right.
No, I agree with you.
I agree with that.
I'll give you, I'll give you
some results from testing, but
I don't the best way of testing.
Maybe self evaluation.
I also agree with you about,
uh, correction and you
often hear the argument,
well, you know, mothers correct
their kids when they start speaking,
otherwise they'd never speak correctly.
That's an...
what's your reaction to that comment?
Actually, they don't.
Of course they don't.
Yeah, of course.
They couldn't possibly
correct every little mistake.
And I've noticed this myself when
I do give lessons in English, if
I correct the other person, they
continue making the same mistake
right there in the very same lesson.
So there's no impact.
And, uh, I find it mildly
annoying if I am corrected without
having asked for corrections.
So to me, the whole correction
issue is I agree that's one of
your themes is that it just creates
more, more tension, more Prozac.
Also it is aimed at conscious learning.
Make a mistake.
The child says I comes to school
every day and you say, no, no.
It's I come to school every day.
The child is supposed to think, oh
yeah, that S goes on the third person
singular, not the first person...
that you look at the studies.
It does...
it is a big disappointment.
As a matter of fact, testing
doesn't really work that well.
So what, uh, what has changed?
I mean, I mentioned in my video that
I first met you in 2003, by the way, I
didn't know when it was that I first met
you, but then I managed to find the Taiwan
lectures book that I bought in Taipei,
and it said they're published in 2003.
And it just so happened that my book
about my own experiences of language
learning was also published in 2003.
And I went to Taipei.
I was at this language conference,
the first one I'd ever attended.
And everybody was thronging into
this lecture room to listen to Dr.
Krashen and I didn't know who Dr
Krashen was, but I remember that I
was so impressed with the sort of
element of simplicity that you brought
to the process of language learning
that I quickly had to buy your book.
What has changed in language
learning since 2003?
Not much.
And let me tell you why.
Good question.
Good question means when I'm prepared
to answer, and this is one of them
that I enjoy answer, uh, here and
there yes, there have been changes.
There's more comprehensible input
than before, but by and large language
teaching is the same as it was in 1945.
Okay.
There's been very little change
and there are good reasons.
Why, how do you find out about it?
Well, you can buy books.
They're, uh, written in, except
for mine they're generally written
what we call tortured prose.
Uh, you don't understand what
the person's talking about.
I can't get through them.
Most of the time professional
journals, the same way.
They're also expensive.
Um, my books, little commercial
message, my books are all for free.
I've put, if you follow me on, uh,
Twitter, you find where to find them.
I, you can download them for free cuz
otherwise nobody's gonna read them.
I can't afford them.
Nobody else can afford them.
The solution to all this is what is
called open access, getting our stuff
out so real people can read it and do it.
Otherwise, nothing is going to
happen cuz nobody can afford this.
That's why we came very little change.
Oh, some positive change came for
me a couple of years ago when the
pandemic started and I offered to
give free webinars free seminars over
the next year, I did like 70 of them.
That helped no question.
I can't do that anymore.
Cause I can't afford it.
Now I charge a little bit, not a lot.
Okay.
That was a commercial message.
Um, but it's hearing about it under...
once they hear it and
understand it, it works.
Getting the word out has been slow.
And I don't know any magic way, cuz people
are still writing incomprehensible papers.
But you know, obviously the way we
learn languages, the way our brains
learn languages, hasn't changed.
That has to be the same, whether
you're in the Amazon or wherever you
are, uh, in so far as the awareness of
comprehensible input, uh, in the language
class, in the schools, my impression
is that there's increasing awareness.
The few times that I've attended the.
What is it?
ACE, American association of teachers,
of whatever it is, AFT something.
Yeah.
You and other proponents of
comprehensible input are extremely
popular amongst the teachers.
Amongst some teachers, the ones who've
kept up with the research, and it's hard
for teachers to keep up, cuz they're
overwhelmed with work and the stuff
is incomprehensible and expensive.
Right.
There have been some
conversions and that'schelped.
The big one of course is Steve Kaufmann.
Okay.
People have begun to
understand the research.
Bill van Patton has been
extremely supportive.
Earl Stevick in the old days, that's
helped a lot, but it still is not
part of common, common knowledge.
But, but I think another
thing that has changed.
So if I go back say 50 years or whatever,
55 years ago, when I was learning Mandarin
Chinese, we had an open reel tape.
And there was not very much
audio material available.
And, um, there were books that were
this thick that you could buy with,
with, uh, things that you could
read with, with vocabulary list.
And I remember even 20, 30
years ago, I was approached
by a local community college.
Would I, you know, contribute towards
a language lab and the budget for
the language lab is like $50,000.
And today I carry on my iPhone a quantity
of audio and text material, obviously,
with, with LingQ, of course, with
access to online dictionaries, with a
tremendous range of functions and the
ability to access individuals who are
offering, you know, content comprehensible
input in French, in, in Chinese.
And all of that stuff now is available on
my iPhone far more valuable than anything
that was in that $50,000 language lab.
So surely a lot has changed.
Yeah.
We'll see.
I haven't seen it yet, but we'll see.
We'll hope that this gets around.
Absolutely.
So you're saying teachers are
not taking advantage of this?
Now it's the knowledge is not yet there.
We're getting better.
Now that you mention ACTFL let me
introduce a little bit of gossip.
You and I were, and I will embarrass you.
You and I were in an actual meeting once.
And I was there and I met my former,
uh, Chinese teacher, uh, ... and we,
and, uh, she invited you to come to
lunch with all the Chinese teachers.
I'll give you the word, they
thought you were fantastic.
Oh, they thought
your ... was just excellent.
And they loved what you said.
So live with that.
Okay.
I'll try to live with it.
Thank you.
But, uh, so, so the world, I think
the, the, uh, One of the things that
I find annoying say here in say in
British Columbia, which is not New
York or Chicago, schools will not offer
certain languages because they say we
don't have a qualified teacher or a
certified teacher for that language.
However, I've always felt if you
had a person who was knowledgeable
about how to use the resources on the
internet, the teacher doesn't have
to be the one providing the language,
doesn't have to be the one that we
learn from explaining the language.
You just need a, a guide, a coach, someone
who can help so that if student A wants
to learn Spanish and student B wants to
learn Chinese or Tagalog or whatever,
there are enough resources out there.
Why is it that schools are hung
up on having a certified certified
teacher before they will offer
that language at the school?
You have just recruited me to your
team, that's a wonderful thing.
I haven't thought about it because I'm
not an iPhone person other than just
basic needs and not into all this stuff.
And it's all around me and I
have pretty much ignored it.
I, you just convinced me,
this is a wonderful way of
solving the problem I think.
Yeah, there are so many
resources out there now.
And, and again, if I look at Canada
where, you know, you must learn French.
So here we are in British Columbia.
We're far away from French
speakers god bless them on
the other side of the country.
So you're expecting kids to learn
French out of some kind of civic duty
because it's an official language.
That's not very motivating.
What if the kid, children, boys,
girls wanna learn Spanish or Swahili.
Why wouldn't you give them a
victory in learning the language
that they're motivated to learn?
Once they've got one language under
their belt,they will be in a better
position to learn French if at some
point they become motivated to do so.
And if they don't become motivated
to learn French, they will not learn.
Absolutely correct.
I think you're right.
I'm I'm part of your team now.
Can I tell you my only French
joke that I managed to pull off?
Is it, is it clean?
More than.
I was in, um, in, uh, Montreal with
a group of Anglophones and we were in
a French area and we went to dinner
and this is my greatest triumph.
Okay.
I'm really proud of this.
The waiter came over and said ... I
raised my hand and I said
...
the worst mistake you can ever make.
He understood what you were saying.
Of course he laughed.
He thought it was great.
Okay.
That was it.
That's the story?
That's it.
Why...
but you know, that's a good example.
So what?
He understood what you were saying.
You mean because you didn't say...
I did it on purpose.
Let me tell you.
Okay.
It was a joke and he
liked it and he laughed.
Okay.
But, but the point is, even if you
didn't do it on purpose, so what?
And I get, like, if I do a video
in some other language and I make a
mistake, then there's always some people
who jump on me and stuff like that.
I mean like why, why does it matter?
Uh, I have never spoken to anyone in
a foreign language, say in, in English
where I felt, you know, I respected that
person less because they made a mistake.
This is a big, and this is again, I'm
sorry to say all these nice things
about you, but I have no choice.
Um, when I had just read what, in
one of your, uh, papers, you said,
don't worry about making mistakes.
Nobody cares.
I'm more interested in what you say.
I was in Mexico at a,
at a one week session.
And I had lunch and dinner with, uh,
Spanish teachersand we spoke Spanish
the whole time and I thought, and I
thought, gee, I'm gonna make mistakes.
And then I had just read
what you wrote and it hit.
I had the best time ever,
very little ..., mostly
...
we gossiped the whole time.
Who was it who said, if you don't
have anything good to say about
someone, come sit next to me?
Okay.
It was so much fun.
Thanks to you not worrying about mistakes.
And it gets back to your point
about the Prozac pill or whatever.
And you've said this there's...
unfortunately, I mean, people should go
to your website and read your material,
but there's so many quotable quotes,
but this, this, what do you call it?
The emo....
emotive filter, no.
The affective filter
affective filter.
Uh, there's a formula I think, attributed
to Lomb Kato that sort of has, you know,
your attitude plus the time you spend with
the language and divided by inhibition,
frustration, all this negative stuff.
Obviously you wanna have a positive
attitude, you wanna spend the time, but
if you can reduce the inhibition, the
fear you're only gonna learn faster.
So why would you bring things in
like, worrying about making mistakes,
correcting people, all this other stuff?
That's gonna increase
that inhibition factor.
And it's only gonna slow down
because most of your mistakes,
you will eventually correct.
So why not let people enjoy
themselves, enjoy the language?
While they're enjoying the language
they're hearing the language, cuz
they're interacting with other
people they're using the language.
Eventually they'll
retrieve the right word.
Eventually, not always, but more
and more they'll speak correctly
as we say, but why inhibit them?
Lomb Kato also said language
is one of the few things where
knowing just a little bit is good.
If you do that in science, you
make mistakes that's serious,
but in language it's all right.
It's positive.
Don't be afraid.
Exactly.
If you, if you build a bridge,
you better get it right.
but when it comes to language, Um,
and, and, and of course people often
ask me, and if I speak in a language
that I'm a bit rusty in and same with
you, you're have a number of languages.
You're not gonna be able to
maintain them all at the same level.
So then people like to, you
know, come in and dump on you.
In my experience, even those
languages that I have I'm
unable really to speak now.
I couldn't quickly bring that language up.
Although at one time I was in the
country using it, but still A,
the time that I spent learning
that language is so valuable.
I had so much enjoyment.
I learned about the country, the
people, the culture, the history, and
B, when I go back there to refresh
that language, I will very quickly
get back to the same level and I'll
enjoy finding my old friends again.
So it's all positive.
All positive.
Yes.
The method I use for getting back at
them is of course pleasure reading
And I'd like to tell a little story.
I live about, well, 40 minutes
from Los Angeles, right.
And I used to go there about twice a week
to see my grandchildren, still addicted.
And of course, to pump iron with
Arnold on the beach, all right.
Arnold, really nice guy, by the way.
Very...
he seems to be, yeah, he seems to be.
Oh my goodness.
You go you're there
doing your bench presses.
He says, oh, can I help you with that?
Try it this way.
You know, very pleasant.
Um, anyway, what do you do driving 40
minutes, twice uh, the same day, twice?
Um, radio used to be good.
Uh, listen to the news, but
now it's all Donald Trump.
Music, they took the good music and
put it on paid to listen stations.
Yeah.
So I stopped at the Santa Monica library.
Okay.
And I got audio books,
books on disc books on tape.
Uh, I couldn't do foreign languages
cuz they only had English and
they didn't have classics.
I'm a college professor.
Okay.
They had bestsellers.
I listened to bestsellers.
They're good.
They're really good.
And I got interested in everyday pop
literature, self-selected and that has
been our main thing in application.
It's not the only way to do it.
Um, my colleague ... MAson has
developed a system, guided self-selected
reading, after her students.
This is English as a foreign language.
After the students have heard
lots of stories she tells and
makes comprehensible, they do
self-selected reading from easy books.
We used to call them graded readers.
They're really comprehensible
books and they're getting better,
they're becoming literature.
I read books by bill van Patton.
I just mentioned him.
My favorite author in Spanish.
And you get better and
better and you enjoy it.
That's been a major breakthrough for me.
That's an easy way of getting the language
back when you've been a little bit rusty.
And I think, uh, I can't remember who,
who it was said that when we go back over
things that we've learned before, in our,
in other words, we're reconnecting certain
neural connections that were there before
we actually end up learning those things.
Interesting.
Yeah.
That, that to relearn really
consolidates your hold on that material.
Um, the other thing is obviously
people's tastes differ.
I happen to like 19th century literature.
So whether when I was learning Russian
or even in a language that I speak
well, like French, if I'm gardening
and I can remember gardening and
listening to French literature.
It elevates your control of the language.
It's just listening to something.
It becomes like music, even if you,
I'm not gaining that many words,
but I'm improving all the time
improving when you use the language.
When you listen, when you read, you're
constantly, constantly improving.
And if you leave it, you might slip back
a bit, but it's not the end of the world.
Yeah, there, it's the problem of access.
And you've just told me how to solve that.
You know, electronic etc.
Electronic is great.
Like, and right now, just to talk a
little bit about LingQ in my Persian
learning we're now beta testing a system.
This might I, in fact, I'd be interested
in your, uh, reaction to this, but I,
I go through these, uh, podcasts, which
are on Iranian identity and Iranian
history, and this is quite serious stuff.
And I do it sentence by sentence,
uh, which is easier because if you're
looking at a whole page a little more
difficult and I can actually get that
sentence translated if I, if I want to.
But the big thing now is I can I
get that sentence then jumbled, when
I'm finished reviewing the words and
I've listened to the thing, then I
go there and it's a form of output.
I find it surprisingly addictive.
So I've got all these
words and phrases jumbled.
I've gotta recreate that sentence.
It is.
It's like trying to speak,
but you're, you're looking
at how the prepositions work.
You're looking at how the, the
verbs work you're looking at
what you thought the word means.
You kind of figured you knew what it meant
when you heard the sentence and when you
read the sentence, but now that you have
to reconstruct that sentence, but you
don't have to reconstruct it from zero.
You don't have to write it all yourself.
You don't even have to remember it.
All you have to do is go in
there and start the first word,
the second, maybe it's a phrase.
It's just, it's a, it's amazing.
It slows me down in terms of
new vocabulary acquisition.
Uh, but it is, it is
surprisingly addictive.
I don't know whether it, I think
it does help my learning because I
think it gives me a better sense of
how the language works, even though
it's, it's, it's less sort of intense
in terms of vocabulary acquisition.
So I, I just mentioned that to you.
What's your immediate reaction?
Yeah, that is again,
I'm learning things new.
I have never thought of this, but
I'm, I'm open about a good idea.
Yeah, maybe once we get it out of
beta, I can send it over to you and
you can, you can have a look at it.
Uh, it is amazing.
Listen, I wonder if we have any questions.
I wonder if Eric is in the
background here, if, uh, any of
the listeners have any questions?
I don't see any in my chat box, but,
uh, if people do have questions,
uh, don't uh, be shy here.
Um, what do we see here, Eric?
Hello, Eric.
Everyone.
Hello?
Okay.
Maybe he'll give us some questions.
Yeah.
Okay.
I mean, I, it's very disappointing that,
um, you know, I'll give you an example
and again, I don't wanna be nasty to our
federal government here in Canada, but
they invested in a language learning app.
Okay.
To help Canadians learn
artificial languages.
First of all, they call it.
M A U R I L Mauril whatever.
No one is gonna find that no
one is gonna look for that.
Call it Canadian official languages,
if you want, people might find it.
But then the whole thing is
based on comprehension questions.
So they work in conjunction with the
CBC radio Canada, and they take certain
TV programs and they prepare them.
And then they prepare a bunch
of comprehension, questions and
activities surrounding those programs.
That means that I cannot choose
the radio program or, or TV
program that is of interest to me.
I only can access whatever they
have selected that they think
should be of interest to me.
And then they force me to do
these comprehension questions and
I hate comprehension questions.
And there's a famous Brazilian educator
who now passed away Rubem Alves,
who said that nothing discourage
the reader as much as being asked
questions about what he or she has read.
What's your reaction to
comprehension questions?
The same as yours.
Absolutely horrible, horrible.
And it is true.
Nothing would discourage me more
than having to ask answer questions.
That's why I like
self-selected reading topics.
I have questions in my mind all the
time, because I'm a human being.
Pleasure reading things you select
has many of the answers, which is a
segue for me to talk about another
of my obsessions not just about
reading itself and reading fiction.
In a nutshell, yes,
it's good for language.
We know that people who read more have
better spelling, grammar, all that
stuff, bigger vocabulary write better.
They also know more people who read
fiction, self selected fiction,
know more about everything.
It's fabulous.
This is an argument for good libraries
and self-selected reading, et cetera.
Finally, people who read more, have
more understanding of others, more
empathy for the rest of the human race.
So there are some people who
really need to read more.
Okay.
I agree with you.
And furthermore research shows and I,
but I can't find that bit of research
right now, but the best sort of...
to track how successful people are
socially, uh, academically, uh, you know,
professionally more than the number of
years spent in school or university or
postgraduate it's how well they read.
It's even more interesting than that.
Okay, I'll take that and move it along.
Big study was done.
Uh, Stanovich in Cunningham, one
of the best studies ever done in
reading, uh, they gave people a test
of second year college students.
They gave them a test of general
knowledge, kind of what you should
know when you graduate secondary
school and had a variety of areas.
You know, science, current events, social
studies, uh, practical stuff, technology,
uh, the best predictor of course, was
familiarity with popular literature.
Which included magazines.
TV was a big zero.
What didn't help was not a predictor how
well you read and your grades in school.
Hmm.
Wow.
So doing your homework
didn't really count.
It's your pleasure reading.
It gives you general
more overall knowledge.
Whoa.
I have a question here from someone who
asks, if you cannot speak to a tutor,
is shadowing talking to yourself ideal?
Any thoughts?
I have no idea.
It's not, none what...
uh, I kind of doubt it, but I'm
speaking just from what I feel,
not from any research on it.
We do it all the time.
We can't help it.
I don't know if it, if, if
it does any good or not.
The, uh, shadowing is this technique
whereby while you're listening to
something, you try to sort of talk
along, you know, repeat what you hear.
I have found that I am rarely
able to continue doing that.
I can do it for a while.
I gave it a shot.
And, and if the material is, is
essentially easy enough, like are
many stories at LingQ where I'm
familiar with story, then I can do it.
But if it's something that's of
interest to me, if I'm listening to
something genuinely interesting, I
don't want to confuse myself by trying
to repeat what the person is saying.
So I've never been able to maintain
that, but there are many people who
do like shadowing, but, uh, again,
not something that I've been able to.
The whole idea of even trying it
out makes me feel uncomfortable.
okay.
Here's some more questions.
What is the ideal ratio of
listening to reading input?
Should one of them be preferred?
Depends on what you can get.
I've never thought of that because
it's always been kind of a struggle
to find the comprehensible input.
But that's another question
I really don't know.
My suspicion again, this is
a suspicion is that there is
an, a, a minimum of listening.
And after that, it doesn't matter.
The more you get of
either the better you are.
I think another consideration
is obviously there's far more
material available in writing.
There's material available only in
audio, like a podcast I'm reluctant to
listen to material where I can't get,
unless I'm very good in the language.
But if I'm at a 30% comprehension level
in a podcast, I want the transcript.
I want to have a chance to
try to understand what I'm
listening to understand.
Uh, but other than that, and the other
thing about listening, of course, it's
easier to do so I can do it in my car.
I can do it while making
breakfast, reading.
I'm committed.
I gotta sit there and read, I can't
read and drive my car at the same time.
So I think it's a function
of what's available to you.
Uh, what time you have to
devote to one or the other task.
Uh, I, and also what you like to do.
So I'm, I think I'm always reluctant
is that you should be 60% reading
and 40% listening or something.
I think depends on the individual.
Yeah, no answer to that.
Here's another one of these questions
that I don't think there's an answer to.
When is the right time to come
back to a previous language?
I'd say, uh, seven o'clock in the evening.
You know, again, it's, it's so
dependent on your circumstance.
If you're about to go to Mexico and you
haven't looked at Spanish for six years,
that's the time to start refreshing
your me, your Spanish, you know?
Uh, what do you think about
the practice of reading aloud?
Uh, listening to someone else read aloud.
Fantastic.
I don't know that your reading aloud
does any good at all it's output and
you're not paying attention to meaning.
I agree.
And again, it's one of these
things that I have tried and have
never been able to continue doing.
Right.
I would, it feels boring
before I even start.
Right.
Here's one though that
comes up all the time.
What do you consider fluent
to be fluent in a language?
Wow.
I, it depends so much on
circumstance, on situations.
Okay.
In some situations I'm actually fluent
and very impressive in languages I can
hardly speak and depends on the person.
Uh, that's so true.
So it is incredibly variable.
Again, I invite someone
else to start working on it.
I, I, my own view.
If you can use the language in a way
that you are not uncomfortable and
the person listening to you is not
uncomfortable, then you're fluent.
And I, if we wanted to be more
specific, I tend to see it
as B2 on the European scale.
In other words, you have enough vocabulary
that you're likely to understand much
of what a native speaker says to you.
And you're likely to be able to express
yourself on a wide range of subjects.
Even with mistakes.
To me, that's fluent.
God, you just made me fluent in Spanish.
Thank you.
All right.
Fantastic.
And here's another one: can
full phonological acquisition
be achieved through input alone?
Good question one.
I'm prepared to answer.
Okay.
Same thing.
Um, I think we're a lot better in
pronunciation than we think we are.
Uh, in fact, I think the ability
to perfectly acquire accents is
there the language acquisition
device never shuts off.
We don't use our best
accents cause we feel silly.
I wanna relate to you the
in incident that started it.
It happened when I was teaching in
Ethiopia a long time ago, and there was
a, a British guy visiting our school,
worked for the British council, I think.
And we talked about his experiences in
high school, French, uh, Secondary school.
He said the final exam you had
to get up in front of your French
teachers and speak to them.
Nothing is more humiliating for a
young man than they have to do that.
So he decided to come in and
make fun of the teachers and show
them up for the fools they were.
He dressed French.
He had a beret.
He had a glass of what looked
like wine and he started to speak.
He says, ah
...
he thought he was making fun of them.
He got the highest grades possible.
He said, where have you been?
That's great.
Why haven't you ever done that in class?
We can't do that because we're
not a member of the group.
It's not us.
Peter Ustinov in an interview,
said - his French is very good.
I've heard him in movies.
He sounds absolutely perfect,
but he doesn't use that accent
when he speaks to native speakers
of French, he has an accent.
We have an output filter and it's
because accent is a marker of group
membership of club membership.
Uh, when I made someone from,
uh, London, I don't start
speaking with a British accent.
I can a little bit.
Okay.
But it seems funny, awkward,
and maybe even feels insulting.
So we have these powerful,
effective blocks.
We're a lot better than we think we are.
I agree with you.
I have said in the past that in order to
pronounce better, even to learn languages
better, we have to have a sort of an
attitude of cultural weightlessness,
you know, and, and, you know, I lived
in Japan and or if a, if say a north
American Anglo Saxon English speaker is
very proud of being, you know, English
speaker they're reluctant to be foolish.
They're reluctant to just be
culturally weightless and just try
to hear the language and repeat
the language and just go for it.
So I totally agree with
what you're saying.
That's been my experience.
Yeah.
I, but it is hard for the
public to accept this.
I got a, um, invitation to meet with
someone I was told was extremely
wealthy business person from
Germany, living in Los Angeles.
And I was driven to his, uh,
house up in the Hills, expensive.
He wanted to get rid of his accent.
And I gave him my little theory there.
Uh, and he said, no, that's ridiculous.
I said, what if I got you a sound
spectrograph and we got native
speakers of English and you
try to max match their pattern.
Yes.
That's how to do it.
I said, it's never gonna work.
He showed me the door
immediately and told me to leave.
People would never believed
this it's there within us.
We can do it.
Don't worry about it.
There's good reason we have an accent.
See, A I personally, if I hear
someone who has, uh, a noticeable
foreign accent, but uses the language.
Well, I, I respect those people.
In fact, more than someone
who has almost no accent.
So there there's no advantage in if
you're being, if people understand you,
there's no real advantage in being like
mistaken for a native, which I don't
think is achievable for most people.
Uh, also I think getting back
to what you were saying, we have
to wanna be part of that group.
So every time I've, you know,
tried to learn the language,
Japanese, French, Chinese, whatever.
I wanna be one of them.
I don't see myself as this foreigner
trying to learn this language.
If I'm in a group with
them, I'm one of them.
That's that kind of
attitude I think helps us.
And so I do believe that that, and oh,
and the other thing I was gonna say.
Okay.
An actor, an actress, they
have to play another role.
Right?
So they are very good at accents because
they're used to the idea of seeing
themselves as not John Smith, but as
this character that they're playing.
And, and on one last note, there
was this American actress whose name
escapes me, but she has a phenomen.
Her pronunciation in French is
flawless, but she still makes
tremendous mistakes with gender.
Yeah.
But like, it's amazing.
She speaks like a French woman, but
the gender is just so difficult to
get the hang of cuz we don't have it
in English, but she, as an actress,
she's able to project herself into
the role of being a French woman.
It's called method acting.
Method acting is where you get the
emotion within our, within yourself.
And then you can.
But it's not real.
It's still acting.
You can do that.
You can do the accent in a film, et
cetera, real life, something else.
However, to some extent, speaking
of foreign language is a game.
To some extent we are imitating the
culture, the language of another
group, we are pretending to be them.
We are acting to some extent
or, or you don't agree?
I think that's fascinating.
Absolutely.
Maybe that's
on that not.
We can, we can end it.
I think we could probably go on for
hours here, uh, talking about language.
Uh, I wanna end by, first of all,
I have my, uh, Ukrainian ... on
today because it's the Ukrainian
national day or day of independence.
And, uh, I think, uh, we all support
Ukraine and, uh, their heroic
struggle against this evil invasion,
but, um, also I wanna tell you
that you have been a big influence.
Uh, because of your wisdom
and your ability, like when I
saw that book in Taipei, which
was like this thin, all right.
And I, I showed the other day in my
video, I got stacks of books that
are full of complicated language and
everything that they said, and these
books was reduced into this book.
And the more we can deal with this instead
of this, the better we can understand,
you know, the process of language earning.
So I thank you.
Well, thank you.
And thank you for all
the help you've given me.
And you're still my therapist.
Appreciate, thank you.
Thank you.
No more Prozac.
Okay.
Bye Steven.